when you think about
the current environment obviously the
federal reserve's been
increasing interest rates and they've
been
conducting quantitative tightening or at
least saying that they're going to do it
how do you think about asset prices
across the spectrum in relation to that
should we just see correlations go
towards one and all asset prices sell
off or should we expect to have some
sort of decoupling in this type of
environment
that's such a great question i think
it's on everyone's mind right now as
kind of the macro framework and monetary
policy kind of dominates the market
narrative right now
and from my perspective
one of the things that you learn in kind
of like entry-level finance and
economics courses is that yields and
asset prices have an inverse correlation
all else being equal and so as we're in
an interest rate environment where
the fed is tightening monetary policy
and yields on treasuries are are moving
higher right um
in that environment we've seen asset
prices across the board whether we're
looking at
stocks or bitcoin and crypto or even
treasuries in the bond market everything
is selling off in this environment and
so from my perspective so long as we
remain in this environment asset prices
are going to have headwinds
um
to to rise and benefit in this
environment right so until we really see
a formal shift
in
basically the yield environment am i
expecting to see a bull market
yeah when you start to think about um
kind of the transition from let's call
the bear market we're in now pretty much
across asset classes into a bull market
is it just when does the fed let their
foot off the gas pedal or is there other
things that you would be looking for
i think there's um some other things
right like the fed is clearly behind the
curve in this environment and so if we
start to see inflation data formally
roll over and kind of sustain that
rollover then i think that could be a a
general foreshadowing of a reversal in
the monetary policy environment but um
if we look generally speaking at
stock market and crypto relative to
monetary policy we can kind of get some
clues as to how these assets have
behaved in the past relative to monetary
policy and so if we look at um when
bitcoin and the stock market bottomed in
2018
it was in december of 2018 when the fed
formally paused their rate hikes and so
we had a formal shift in the monetary
policy outlook and environment when did
asset prices bottom in 2020 including
crypto right is the fed came out and
formally said we are here to provide
infinite support to the monetary and
financial system and asset prices ripped
higher when did stocks and bitcoin and
crypto broadly peak in november of 2021
when the fed announced that they were
tapering so
it's a it's a super simple and kind of
like crude metric for where asset prices
are going to go going forward but it's
been super accurate in this kind of like
monetary wonderland that we're in right
yeah when we start to look at certain
parts of the market uh there's aspects
that i know you've been paying attention
to that we just haven't talked about
that much on this show so i'd love to
kind of go through this uh the first is
this idea of loans and leases uh and
you've identified that it's one
expanding at a rapid pace um but also
there's this relationship with inflation
so maybe explain a little bit
about this loans and leases and how
people should think about uh this as
part of the financial system sure so
i spent two years working on the
commercial banking side as a portfolio
analyst so i got really familiar with
looking at this kind of data overall
and i've been out of that field now for
almost two years so nothing i'm about to
say is indicative of like my former
employer or anything like that right but
um
essentially when i look at loans and
leases it i think it's very important
because as we think about the
inflationary dynamics
obviously the fed came out and they
printed all of this money and operated
qe through like crazy right for 24
months plus
and
obviously the monetary base in m2
expanded during that period but until we
see that money really come into the
actual real economy and leave the
financial and banking system
i think that's going to bring more
inflationary pressures in so in the
upper bound of this chart we're looking
at the nominal value of total loans and
leases that have been issued by
commercial banks in the united states
and it just hit an all-time high in
early june at roughly 11.3 trillion
dollars
in the lower bound of this chart what
i've done is i've actually denominated
loans and leases and i've divided it by
m2 money supply so this gives us
somewhat of an indication of credit
creation
relative to the monetary base and if we
look over time basically since 2000 we
get these distinct kind of rolling overs
at the tops and curling back up during
an uptrend and it appears as though for
the past six to seven months loans and
leases relative to the monetary base are
starting to increase again and i think
that's one of the main reasons why we've
continued to see inflationary pressures
in 2022.
so when you see this basically people
are just borrowing what was cheap
capital now becoming more expensive
and they're using other people's money
essentially to go ahead and buy assets
to consume do whatever uh they're doing
from a spending standpoint and that
ultimately influx of kind of like net
new capitals driving up asset prices and
also consumables
and kind of increasing demand and
therefore until we start to see relief
here then we shouldn't expect inflation
to come down materially and part of the
fed's actions to increase the cost of
capital is to drastically reduce the
demand for these loans and leases and
therefore bring inflation down i think
that's a that's a fair assessment pomp
and
um you know this this data here loans
and leases includes consumer loans it
includes loans secured by real estate it
includes commercial and industrial loans
so this is really a full picture of the
total credit market if you will in terms
of the business and consumer demand for
new loans
got it and so when we start to see um
this number come down how quickly would
you expect it to come down is it
something where uh okay now that
everyone realizes the fed's serious at a
75 basis point hike and we should expect
to see this data like fall off a cliff
or is it something that's more gradual
and kind of takes time for people to
recognize the market is changing the
cost of capital is changing and
therefore uh i was going to get a loan
in september but actually i'm not going
to do that and so that would take a
couple of months before it got kind of
quote unquote priced into the market or
revealed in this data
sure so uh one main point on this that
i'd like to say is that i expect to see
loans and leases continue to expand even
if we go into a recessionary environment
because even in that environment
businesses are going to need capital to
operate
right and so
the one thing that i'm really going to
be paying attention to is the rate of
change and the growth rate of loans and
leases so if we look at um the
year-over-year growth in loans and
leases it's about nine percent and
what's the inflation rate right now
measured by the cpi it's eight point six
percent and there's no rule or law or
theory that says that these should grow
in line with each other um
but i think if we want to see inflation
data materially roll over we're going to
need to see a
deceleration in the growth rate of loans
and leases i think that's the way that i
would put it
and on a year-to-date basis loans and
loans and leases are up almost four and
a half five percent so again we're
seeing ample demand from businesses to
acquire new debt and expand production
whatever the case is i'm not sure
exactly what they're using the capital
for per se
it could be to buy back their own stock
or
increase their dividend right i'm not
sure
um
but even if we look at sub sectors of
loans and leases and we look at
something like commercial and industrial
loans which i really view as something
like capital expenditures or
growth in the production
something of that nature
that number right now is about 2.6
trillion dollars and so that's also
growing at a pretty solid rate much
slower than overall loans and leases but
still increasing so that to me just
implies that credit creation is on the
rise